the republican national convention in
cleveland
the most apocalyptic thing ever to
happen to that city
and bear in mind their river has
repeatedly caught fire
now it has been over for a few days but
we thought it might be worth taking a
few extra minutes to try and figure out
what the just happened because you
know you are dealing with a pretty
unconventional convention when a speaker
opens with this statement
my name is dana white i am the president
of the ultimate fighting championship
the only way that would have made sense
is if his next words were
and i have clearly sleepwalked here
please gently walk me from the stage and
return me to my family
they are very worried now he was
actually there to speak to donald
trump's business acumen
a repeated theme throughout the whole
week he
gets stuff done donald trump is a proven
leader
innovator entrepreneur when donald trump
is in charge
all that counts is ability effort and
excellence
he has created jobs for thousands and is
one of the greatest visionaries of our
time
now now before you laugh you cannot say
trump
isn't a visionary for a long time he was
the only one who envisioned himself
as a presidential nominee he is
basically what happens if the secret
gets into the wrong hands but that
message of trump as a skilled manager
was somewhat undercut by the fact the
entire convention
was a mismanaged show from melania
trump using a partly plagiarized speech
to ted cruz being booed off the stage
for not endorsing donald trump
to the fact that supposedly donald trump
knew ted cruz wouldn't endorse him
and didn't care the decision came as no
surprise to trump who tweeted
i saw his speech two hours early but let
him speak anyway
no big deal yeah but that's not
reassuring
if the captain of the titanic had
tweeted after the fact i saw that
iceberg two hours before and sailed into
it anyway
no big deal you wouldn't think wow that
captain sure ran a tight ship
well you know it's actually fitting that
trump had seemingly done
so little to prepare for his party's
convention giving that the party itself
had done so little to prepare for donald
trump
after the last election the gop
published a postmortem report
titled the growth and opportunity
project
analyzing their mistakes and laying out
a plan to expand
their appeal now it featured passages
like many minorities
wrongly think that republicans do not
like them or want them in the country
and we must emphasize the importance of
a welcoming
inclusive message in particular when
discussing issues that relate directly
to a minority group
unfortunately over the past year that
report and its carefully considered
suggestions
has been overshadowed by a different
report titled
literally everything donald trump has
ever said and done
because this is a guy who suggested
building a wall to keep mexicans out
and advocated a temporary ban on muslims
entering the country
so it's like making a new year's
resolution to eat healthy
and then spending the next year only
eating meals so large
that they're free if you eat them in one
city
but amazingly through all the chaos and
confusion this week
one theme did emerge and it was
accidentally summarized best
and i can't believe i'm saying this by
antonio cebarto jr
an imdb page awarded actor who
delivered a relatively restrained speech
before
opening his heart regarding president
obama to abc news
first of all i don't believe that the
guy is a christian i don't believe he
follows
um the god that i love and the jesus
that i love you believe that president
obama is a muslim
is that what you're saying absolutely
and that is based on what you feel in
your heart
that's what i believe yeah you know what
i have the right to believe that
and you have the right to go against
that but i believe it
now what's revealing there isn't his
mistaken belief that president obama is
a muslim
it's also not the big shock that antonio
cebato jr star of the actual vh1 reality
show
my antonio is still both alive and an
idiot
no what is truly revealing is his
implication that believing something to
be true
is the same as it being true because if
anything
that was the theme of the republican
convention this week
it was a four day exercise in
emphasizing feelings
over facts people around the country
feel the obama administration has kicked
them to the curb
our country right now is a very bad spot
you can feel it the vast majority of
americans today
do not feel safe there's a lot of
americans out there who feel like
democrat politicians have taken them for
granted
the whole economy feels stuck what
do you mean it feels stuck the economy
is about numbers
feelings are supposed to be irrelevant
uh incidentally
is a phrase that's inscribed on every
british marriage certificate
and this focus this focus on feelings
reached its apex in donald trump's
acceptance speech which was light on
concrete policy
but heavy on provoking strong emotions
decades of progress made in bringing
down crime
are now being reversed i know
that corruption has reached a level
like never ever before in our country
poverty and violence at home war and
destruction
abroad 180 000
illegal immigrants with criminal records
order deported from our country
are tonight roaming free to threaten
peaceful citizens holy
he sounds like he's about to announce
the first annual hunger games
but but look it is worth noting that
since president obama took office
crime rates the flow of illegal
immigrants over our borders and claims
for unemployment benefits have all
declined and yet frighteningly
when reporters started pointing that out
it didn't seem to matter
just watch as newt gingrich brushed off
any effort to fact-check trump's claims
about the u.s crime rate
violent crime is down the economy it is
not
down in the biggest cities violent crime
murder rate is down
how come then how come it's up in
chicago up in baltimore there are
pockets where
certain certainly we have towers you're
national capital your third
third biggest city but violent crime
across the country is down the average
american i will bet you this morning
does not think crime is down does not
think they are safer
but it is we are safer and it is now no
that's your view
yeah i just don't know but what i said
about what i said
no what i said is also a fact no it
isn't
no it isn't it's only a fact that that's
a feeling people have
this is a graph of the violent crime
rate it's not a raw shark test
you can't infer anything you like from
it
and sure you can cherry pick recent
upticks in some cities but the
overall trend across the country during
the obama presidency and indeed for the
last 25
years is down but newt wasn't done
the current view is the liberals have a
whole set of statistics which
theoretically may be right
but it's not where human beings are but
what you're saying is but
hold on mr speaker because you're saying
liberals use these numbers they use this
sort of magic math this is
the fbi statistics they're not a liberal
organization no they're
what i said is equally true people feel
it more threat yes
they feel it but the facts don't support
it as a political
candidate i'll go with how people feel
and i'll let you go with the
theoreticians
he brought he just brought a feeling to
a
fact fight and and it is worth taking
um just a moment to seriously consider
what gingrich was saying there because
think about it i think we can all agree
that candidates can create feelings in
people and what gingrich is saying is
that feelings
are as valid as facts so then by the
transitive property
candidates can create facts which is
terrifying because that means someone
like donald trump
can essentially create his own reality
and that is the closest thing to an
actual magic spell
i think i've ever seen and if you're
thinking well hold on eventually
reality will set in because if elected
trump would actually have to deal with
facts
well i'm not so sure about that just
this week the times reported that not
only was john kasich asked if he had any
interest in the vice presidency by the
trump campaign
he was offered quite a lot more donald
trump jr even called
one of john kasich's top aides and said
that if he
wanted the job he could even be in
charge of
foreign and domestic policy which of
course is
kind of everything yeah exactly
the only thing that is not foreign
policy or domestic policy
is space policy which leads me to
believe donald trump's entire goal is to
eventually own
the moon but but it gets better because
apparently when kasich's advisers asked
what trump
would be in charge of the response was
making
america great again which objectively
is not a job but i guess it feels like
one
and it seems that's all that
matters now
now the trump family disputed that story
naturally
but it does often seem like trump is
more interested in attention
than the hard work of getting things
done in a complicated political system
just last night he tweeted out what
seemed to be his main takeaway from this
convention
okay okay first
24 out of 75 is 32
not 33 but that doesn't matter that
clearly doesn't matter
the point is look the point is the
notion that donald trump would be a
hands-off president might actually
represent
the best case scenario here the much
more frightening prospect would be if he
were hands on
because between those 24 minutes of
applause was a symphony of
bile and race baiting remember this is a
man who has retaliated against
journalists
and at various points has advocated
killing terrorist families
endorsed torture and expressed
admiration for leaders like kim jong-un
saddam hussein and vladimir putin his
message this week
was the message of every strong man ever
the world is dangerous and only i can
make you safe
and if that sounds scary there have been
warning signs
just watch this dvd extra from the first
season of the apprentice
it's a it's a music video they made and
it gives you a sense of how donald trump
envisions himself
this is a dictatorship and i'm the
dictator
oh sure it's funny now to hear him say
he's a dictator as a voice in the
background says
slave to the master over and over again
but unless we're careful by this time
next year that could be america's new
national anthem
you